CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was a deputy
director and acting director of the CIA
during the campaign he supported Hillary
Clinton for president is with us now
from Washington Michael good morning
good morning Charlie we know it is not
unusual to collect opposition research
we know on this case though that this
was a lawyer who claimed to be art
claimed to have some connection with the
Russian government what's the
significance from a national security
perspective Charlie I think it is highly
inappropriate for an American campaign
to meet with a foreign official whether
that foreign official is connected to a
government or not because it allows a
foreign national to potentially
influence the outcome of an election so
the meeting should never have happened
that's one issue the second issue is
that this is the second time multiple
times now where Jared Kushner has not
reported a meeting with a foreign
official on his hidden on his form to
get his security clearance was that a
mistake or was that intentional and then
third I'd say that that there was no
collusion that happened in this meeting
but the fact that they were willing to
do the meeting suggests to me that a a
willingness to collude and that's what
Bob Muller is going to have to dig into
is it illegal it I'm not a lawyer I
don't think it's illegal but it
certainly shows a willingness to collude
Senator McCain said we just heard him
say it's time to move forward with the
Russian election meddling but there
should be a price to pay a Mike do you
agree with that statement and if so what
is a price that should be paid yeah so
my biggest concern in the in the Trump
Putin meeting was a willingness to move
forward without any accounting for what
the Russians did it is very important
that Putin pay a price for what he did
so that it will deter him going forward
I think that's what Senator McCain was
talking about and I agree with him
completely there's got to be deterrence
going forward so that Putin does not do
this again
but what's that price what is it so I
think the price is what the US Senate
has now passed overwhelmingly which is
additional saying
Shinzon Russia the Trump the Trump
Whitehouse opposes those additional
sanctions but I think that's what's
required to get Putin's attention I want
to turn to Isis too because we know that
Iraqi troops are celebrating in Mosul
this morning their government says it
has reclaimed Iraq second-largest city
from Isis we saw these soldiers waving
iraqi fly flags and then the holding the
ISIS flag essentially upside down we
know there's some pockets of resistance
that remain but a Rock's prime minister
was seen walking through the streets
this morning they took control from over
the city's been control of Isis for
three years what's the significance do
you think Mike so I think it is
significant that we have regained Mosul
this was the big symbolic victory you'll
remember for Isis when they took it but
nobody should nobody should think that
this fight is over eliminating the
Caliphate does not mean victory for us
the fight will go on they will become a
terrorist group an insurgent group there
are still thousands of them in Iraq they
will have to be rooted out and and
importantly the political situation in
Iraq is going to need to be resolved the
Sunnis are going to have to have a sense
of ownership in the future of their
country or they're going to continue to
support extremist groups and also the
Baghdad government is now going to have
to face the Kurds who are interested in
independence so the political part of
this is going to get much harder in the
months ahead all right Michael thank you
thank you very much